hi Nora at Cisco we say that there are
two equalizers in life the internet and
education the internet is global and now
education can be global there are many
institutions in the region that are
connecting to educational organizations
across the world and giving access to
their curriculum I have also seen in
Lebanon for example a few years ago
young students sharing some that some of
their experiments over the internet with
students and other countries across the
world so with the internet today and if
there's willingness in the educational
system in your country you can connect
your schools to the Internet and have a
dialogue with other organizations across
the world see different curriculum
different ways of thinking and at the
same time you know there will be respect
for your culture and your own creativity
so the internet and education to
equalizers in life both global today